يوما بعد يوم تسعى المنصات على اختلاف
انواعها واسمائها الى تطوير مزاياها
وخدماتها للمستخدمين تويتر من بين تلك
التطبيقات التي يسعى ايلون ماسك لتطويره
منذ بدايه استحواذه عليه فبعد ان اعلن امس
عن البدء في اكبر عمليه لحذف حسابات
المستخدمين غير ناشطين وعن دعمه لصانع
محتوى فاجا ماسك متابعيه باضافه ميزه
الرسائل المشفره والمكالمات عبر تويتر
وقال في تغريده قريبا ستتوفر المحادثات
الصوتيه وعبر الفيديو في حسابك مع اي شخص
في هذا العالم وعلى هذه المنصه وبالتالي
سيمكنك التحدث الى الناس في اي مكان دون
ان تعطيهم رقم هاتفك وستنطلق خدمه الرسائل
المشفره غدا يمكن ان يكون هذا التحديد ضمن
التحديث الذي اعلنا عنه العام الماضي
تويتر تطبيق كل شيء والذي قال انه سيوفر
مزايا مثل الرسائل المباشره المشفره
والتغريدات الطويله وخدمات المدفوعات
وبالتالي يمكن ان يكون تويتر منافسا لغيره
من التطبيقات التي تستعمل ذات الميزات مثل
واتساب والذي قال عنه ماسك لانه يمكن او
لا يمكن الوثوق به ردا على تغريده لاحد
مهندس تويتر كتب فيها ان واتساب كان
يستخدم الميكروفون في الخلفيه بين مكانه
دائما
ما تحدث به ايلون ماسك هو مهندس تويتر لم
يمر مرور الكرام عند شركه واتساب التي
نشرت بيانا رسميا قالت فيه انها كانت على
اتصال بمهندس تويتر والذي نشر مشكله في
هاتفه بالواتساب قالت انها تعتقد انما حصل
هو خطا في نظام التشغيل اندرويد يؤدي الى
خطا في لوحه بيانات الخصوصيه الخاصه بهم
وانهم قاموا بالطلب من شركه جوجل بالتحقيق
فيها ومعالجتها اكدت ان اتصالات واتساب
محميه عن طريق التشفير ولا يمكن سماعها
حتى من الشركات نفسها ولابد من الذكرى ان
واتساب ايضا كشف عن تطويره ميزه جديده
تتيح لمستخدمه تعديل الرساله بعد ارسالها
بشرط ان يتم التعديل خلال خمسه عشره دقيقه
وسيتم كتابه ان رساله تم تعديلها بجانبها
فبدلا من ان يقوم الشخص بحذف الرساله
بالكامل او ارسال رساله اخرى يقوم
بتعديلها فقط بدات الميزه التجريبيه ظهور
على واتساب ويب ورصدها عدد كبير من
مستخدمي التطبيق مؤخرا قام باطلاق ميزات
تشغيل حساب واتساب على اكثر من جهاز وفي
وقت واحد على كل عن جديد صراعات ماسك ينضم
الينا عبر زوم من الرياض عبدالله سبع محرش
شؤون التقنيه في عربيه عبد الله حياك اهلا
بك معنا في تفاعلكم من خدمه الرسائل
المشفره الى خدمه المكالمات الصوتيه
ومحادثات الفيديو الى اي مدى بالفعل تويتر
يحتاج اليوم الى هذه الميزات
اول شيء يعطيكم العافيه تويتر قاعد يتحول
من منصه اجتماعيه بسيطه الى شيء اشمل من
ان احنا نعرفه تويتر قاعد يحاول يضم كل
الخدمات تحت منصه واحده وهذا كان اللي
يسعى اليه الناس من البدايه انه يحاول انه
يشتري المنصه ويحولها الى منصه ثانيه
تويتر لن تبقى كما كانت لن تبقى كما نحن
تعرفنا عليها في بدايتها خلال سنوات
الماضيه تقريبا هي لها اكثر من عشره سنوات
حاليا موجوده فلذلك راح يكون في تغييرات
جدا كبيره لاحظنا مثلا في الشهور الماضيه
اطلقوا ميزه التغريدات الطويله جدا هذا
خلاها قريبه جدا من التدوينات اللي احنا
متعودين عليها مسار المستخدم حاليا يقدر
يدخل على تغريده وحده يقرا خبر كامل يقرا
تدوينه كامله من احد المستخدمين بعدها بدا
يدعم مميزات ثانيه وهذا الشيء الاساسي
اللي كان له ماسك يقولها من البدايه ولازم
تعرفون
تويتر حاليا قاعد يتحول من منصه التواصل
الاجتماعي الى شيء اخر لا تستغربون خلال
السنه القادمه يكون موجود في تويتر عملات
رقميه قادر انك تدفع من خلال تويتر لاي
عبد الله فقط نركز على هذه الميزه مختلفه
معاك نستغل وجودك معانا نركز على هذه
الميزه ميزه المكالمات الصوتيه والمحادثات
الفيديو البعض من مستخدمي تويتر وهي منصه
تعتبر اكثر نخبويه اكثر كازا مقارنه بباقي
المنصات كسناب شات او انستجرام اعتبروها
يعني خرق للخصوصيه ان يقوم اي شخص في هذا
العالم من دون ان يكون له رقم او لديه رقم
تليفونك ان يتصل فيك ويحادثك لو نتحدث عن
اليه عمل هذه الميزه في تطبيق خاص تويتر
ما راح يكون اي شخص في العالم قادر يتواصل
معاك لا راح تكون موجوده داخل الرسائل
الخاصه انت اذا سمحت للناس انك تتواصل
معاك في رسائل خاصه راح يكون بامكانهم
انهم يتواصلون معاك زي فكره سناب شات
بالضبط الان في سناب شات اي شخص يتواصل
معك اذا كان هو موجود عندك في الرسائل
الخاصه بالسناب شات قادر يتواصل معك فهذه
هي راح تكون نفس الطريقه اي شخص انت
سامحنا انه يتواصل معاك في تويتر عن طريق
الرسائل الخاصه راح يكون عنده امكانيه انه
يدخل عليك ويتواصل معاك عن طريق الاتصال
فالفكره ما فيها مشاكل تهدد خصوصيه
المستخدمين انما هي فكره معمول فيها في كل
المنصات طيب اذا هي معمول فيها في سناب
شات اذا هي معمول فيها في الفيسبوك اذا هي
معمول فيها في انستجرام ليه ما فيها مشاكل
تخصصيه يوم عملت فيها تويتر صار فيها
مشاكل خصوصيه الامر جدا سلس بسيط خصيه
المستخدم لا زالت في امان ما راح يكون في
اي مشاكل انما هي ميزه جديده متاحه
للمستخدمين انت حاب تستفيد منها وتجربها
جربها انا من الناس مثلا الى الان ما
استفدت من خدمه الاتصال الفيديو او الصوتي
في انستجرام لان
ما عندي في الرسائل الخاصه بالانستقرام
وانا استخدمها فلذلك اتوقع للامر راح يكون
عندي سيان في تويتر لكن هل المستخدمين
البقيه راح يستخدمون المنصه ويعتمدون
عليها في الاتصال والتواصل ممكن ذلك خاصه
انه راح تساهم في توسع المنصه بشكل اكبر
في بعض الدول طيب عبد الله يعني الملفت
انه في الوقت الذي يسعى فيه ماسك لاستخدام
نفس ميزات واتساب يقوم في الوقت ذاته
بانتقاد واتساب وميزاته ويقول انه تطبيق
غير موثوق هل يندرج ذلك في اطار المنافسه
طبيعي جدا واتساب قاعد يتحول حاليا من
تطبيق تواصل بين المستخدمين الى منصه
اجتماعيه واتساب لو تحول الى منصه
اجتماعيه راح يهدد كل منصات التواصل
الاجتماعيه المختلفه لذلك الفيسبوك شرط
التطبيق بمليارات الدولارات الواتساب عنده
شعبيه جدا كبيره وعنده قدره انه في يوم
وليله يتحول من منصه عاديه الى المنصه
اللي يستهدف يعني ايلون ماسك عندها هدف
وقول انه يتحول الى تطبيق يشبه تطبيق وي
شات الصيني الواتساب عند القدره انه يوصل
لهذا الموضوع اسرع من التويتر لو طبق هذا
الموضوع لكنه المنافسه بين الشركات من
صالح المستخدمين في النهايه راح يشوف
مميزات جدا كثيره خلال السنوات القادمه
يسرع من وتيره التطوير ويسرع من تبني
الخدمات الجديده اللي يحتاجونها
المستخدمين هنا السؤال عبد الله يعني من
الدفع مقابل التوثيق الى اليوم نشوف رسائل
مشفره مكالمات ومحادثات فيديو ما الصراعات
المتوقعه من ترامب في تويتر كخبير في هذا
الشهر
متوقع انه يدخل
واضح ان التاثير السياسي
انا متاكد انه راح يكون في صراعات ما بين
تويتر وانستجرام خلال السته شهور القادمه
خاصه تويتر قاعد تغير من طريقه تقديم
المحتوى داخل المنصه قاعد تدعم المستخدم
بشكل جدا كبير طبعا في صراع واضح حاليا مع
تيك توك لكنه الصراع هذا على قولتهم هادئ
جدا بسيط جدا لان احتمال يكون في حجب لتيك
توك في في الاشهر القادمه لذلك لو تم حجم
تيك توك في امريكا او اي دوله اخرى راح
يتوجه لمستخدمين المنصات البديله وتويتر
راح تكون ضمن هذه المنصات خاصه مع دعم
مميزات مختلفه يحتاجونها المستخدمين
بانتظار سرعات ترامب في التروس سوشيال هذه
المره شكرا لك عبد الله السبع محرر الشؤون
التقنيه عربيه حدثنا شكرا لك
[موسيقى]